are you happy with how things ended you
people are in for it
talk to me about your reaction when you
read the script for your final episode a
wife I was I was really pleased with
that I mean I thought they did an
amazing job
overall with over the whole the whole
season but with Jamie also just believe
yeah it made sense I was just like numb
I was just numb when I read like my last
page because it's just so sad it's so
sad that like that is the last time like
I'm reading half my character you know
and it's just got to go on a long long
walk it felt like because knowing how
the whole thing ends it felt like you
had suddenly sort of burdened with this
huge huge secret that millions of people
around the world wanted to wanted to
know I think that we would just relieved
I well I was certainly relieved that we
had an ending that we could send out
into the world and be proud of and happy
to talk about it I was really happy yeah
I was really happy pleased
have you shot your final scenes yet and
are you happy with how things ended bad
season ever
what was it like shooting those final
scenes though and you knew it was mine
sighs so sappy then everyone gets ready
for the emotion and everyone's that
being like oh it's gonna be the lot how
many more takes are we gonna we're just
gonna and then it kind of wears off and
it was just really emotional like I feel
like everything you do it's like you can
start to get yourself so down being like
this is the last time I'm gonna read
script and this is like the last time
I'm gonna be in this location and like I
got to a point where I had to just stop
doing that so it's gonna just have like
a nervous breakdown yeah I was very
excited mmm I'm very happy for the way
that my character is gonna end up with
Game of Thrones
I just remember thinking oh the boys
have done a good job I remember when I
read the final episode okay I got up and
actually genuinely had some pace around
my floor a bit Wow
there you go that was just cuz my leg
said this is sort of just seems like an
added bonus that we're getting to watch
it and celebrate it now I'm um it's I'm
kind of I said to Rose the other night I
was like we've been tethered by this
show for a long time we've loved it and
now we get to enjoy the fine on the
wrong it took me a long time to actually
digest the storyline this season I
thought they did a good job
listen not everybody's gonna be happy
not everybody's gonna be sad it's it's
it you have to remember we're a bit like
real-life we're not gonna tape ink
pretty ribbon on this show is probably
not gonna happen well that'd be fair to
say yeah I thought all of the things you
could possibly feel and hopefully that's
what people will feel when they see
there are no better writers in
television and Dan Weiss and David
Benioff they ended it brilliantly better
than I could have imagined and you
people are in for
[Music]
[Applause]